I think the tasted fish all over my
mouth bag inside a bag Oh double bag oh
no it's not like a cat that's in the bag
I know exactly what that is oh we
haven't even had it it's already
terrible much better than it's always
gonna taste but no you like it no that's
sweet
oh no no it turns bad it was good and
then it was bad it's so fishy though
like I'm having an aquarium I love it
taro crispy fish snack spicy flavor
another fish ah more fish who put you up
to this my girlfriend they look like
dried skin Tiffany some lotion and sort
of carve a triangle off of a money oh
these are like fishing Doritos Oh God
oh um they taste like dry skin I think
it's gross that they're making fish meat
into chips I'm not gonna try cycle this
is so disgusting
I love it this is great he's always
taking on a journey and I never like
where we go yup
Oh cover just like or pop this tastes
like for Bob these are really good okay
well I see an off device for like you
that's just a guy that makes he's a chef
he's like I'm the only smart one morning
sugar cuttlefish all right Colin fish
I'm now our corn pops just cuddle fish
flavor is that what I'm Lorraine yeah
these are scallop flavored lays this
looks familiar
I have the fish wet
this one's a little too much scallops
whole thing is like it's texture it's
buttery texture you put it into a chip
form just got that taste that's like I
don't mind these oh all my senses are
rebelling against me now like a seashell
like somebody's bad breath
that's not bad it starts off in a really
good place okay here's what it does have
it has this like hot cheeto appeal so
like what you do is just keep eating
them so you never get to that end moment
we're like what was that
we got meat crop yeah it's like if you
made a rice krispies treat out of a
block of instant ramen let's see what
happens in the mouth hello what is it
it's got a good texture all right sure I
think I can't decide what it is old soy
sauce there's like we're eating like a
loofah a great garnish yeah just like
the memory of a Chinese dish I don't
know if I like this memory yeah this is
really good I like that I just want to
keep eating more great with dinner too
great with dinner too great Lou dinner
too also works as an adhesive I don't
know what do you flavor there I like it
they're great
tae-bo